because it's looking good for him
against the um young chris of duda
will be the winner of that quarter final
it will be over after only
two games so um could be looking very
good for the american
early day if he's able to win this game
wow and
i just showed a variation that i thought
was impossible magnus carson said no i'm
going to go for it
so i don't know how i accidentally
predicted
what was going to happen there um daniel
dubov he would have been
shocked by this he thought it was
impossible because of the move i
highlighted bringing a pawn down
with a double attack against white's
knight against white's bishop um
but there is a hidden resource um daniel
dubov
i mean he has to go for that pawn push i
think there's simply no other way to
justify the fact white has just won a
pawn
with his last move he can't take that
bishop because of that knight fork
um so daniel dubop he his hand is forced
he has to push a pawn forward attacking
that white knight
then we will see magnus carson's idea
carlson meanwhile smiling because he
knows he's
he's tricked off he surprised him is
that why why we're seeing magnus
crossing with us smile a grin on his
face there
he just tricked them
why is magnus crossing having a huge
laugh here david
i mean unless he's listening to us i'm
not sure kaya
remember he laughed the other day and we
asked him and he couldn't remember why
he was laughing
well this is a bigger laughter this is
the reason why you can see
uh you know he's turning dubose
philosophy against himself do you
remember duval
dubois famously said when my pieces are
attacked i
counter attack and uh here it goes so
magnetic magnus has attacked the queen
and it's
the computers haven't killed chess no
not quite
and i don't think they ever will um
magnus carson he loves the game and he's
loving this moment
um white there pushing forward with
opponent against black queen
um maybe if we bring up the board if we
can keep an eye on the players just to
see where the magnus keeps laughing
um as well so in this position that we
well i left it earlier saying black was
about to win a piece
attacking the knight attacking the
bishop one of them will drop off magnus
came up with an even deeper idea
so he'd seen this position three moves
in advance already but he looked
even further he pushes his pawn forward
attacking the black queen
and no matter where the black queen goes
say it retreats both of white's pieces
are attacked the bishop
and this knight but
but magnus maybe the reason he's
laughing is because he can save one of
his pieces he can drop his bishop back
and now attacking counter-attacking the
black knight so when his own night drops
he wins the black knight and white comes
out with an extra pawn
genius by magnus carson and he's loving
this yeah
it looks like that suddenly uh wow